hide your kids hide your wife they are
trying to defund the police this is the
Democratic response to the riots that
are ravaging cities across the country
and they're not just threatening it it's
not just an idle threat they're actually
doing it the Minneapolis City Council
voted overwhelmingly veto-proof majority
9 out of 13 members to defund the police
because that'll make the situation a lot
better won't it this is now being
threatened not just in Minneapolis but
in cities around the country we'll get
into all of it lock your doors I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
if I look or sound a little different
than I usually do it's because I'm in
Washington DC senator Cruz invited me
out here for a stogie on our last
episode of verdict I decided to take him
up on that I said oh that sounds like a
lot of fun haven't seen senator Cruz in
a while so I fly out got to tell you
something folks there's a whole lot of
fire around here
not too many stogies I don't see there's
a lot if I wanted to light my stogie
there are a lot of places that I could
do that but not not too not too many
stogies themselves no places open when I
tried to get to my hotel last night I I
was stopped by the National Guard there
was no way for several blocks around my
hotel to get there so then we got out of
the car walked all the way up to the
hotel the country feels like a war zone
if frankly it's even beyond the country
obviously it's in Minneapolis it's in
Los Angeles it's in Washington it's in
New York's all over the place rioters
looters arsonists but it see them
outside the country you see images in
Brussels you see images in Paris it just
feels like the whole Western world is on
fire and just when you think okay things
can't possibly get any worse
that's the pessimistic view well the
optimistic view is yes they can get
worse because the policy that's now
being proposed to deal with this is to
defund the police departments this is
some radical radical stuff just the
latest evidence that no reasonable
person can support the BLM movement okay
people think that BLM just means that
you think black lives matter that's not
what it means we'll get into some of the
radical aims of BLM
I think people are beginning to wake up
to this even people on the left even
people like JK Rowling the author of
Harry Potter are waking up to the
pernicious effects of radical left ISM
we will get into all of that but first
we got to start with this cop thing
because it's really really dangerous
stuff and it's being pushed by very
high-level politicians Ilhan Omar the
Democratic Representative member of the
squad young socialists in Congress she
is calling explicitly to defund the cops
will never stop saying not only do we
need this in
we're in police but we need to
completely dismantle the Minneapolis
Police Department
[Applause]
the Minneapolis Police Department is
rotten to the roots and so when we
dismantle it we get rid of that cancer
and we allow for something beautiful to
rise and that reimagining allows us to
figure out what Public Safety looks like
for us now of all the crazy things that
she just said of all the scary things
she just said it's this last one that
worries me the most because I think a
lot of left wingers are forgetting that
the Committee of Public Safety is the
name of the French revolutionary group
that chopped everybody's heads off
during that war maybe they do remember
that actually maybe it's not not such an
accident this kind of language is not
the sort of measured statesmen like
language that we're used to hear it or
people saying well look the police have
problems maybe but we need to reform
them
no they're passed reform they want to
dismantle the whole thing because they
think that they're vicious and vile and
they're killers they use that word
killers and it's not just obviously
Ilhan Omar is very far left-wing she's a
huge radical but even the ostensibly
moderate measured statesman like mayor
of Los Angeles Eric Garcetti
went out he gave a public speech at an
AME Church in Los Angeles and he
explicitly called the cops killers I got
calls from mayor's around the country
some of them saying I'm so exciting the
other ones saying what the hell do you
do now I got a shift money that's
exactly the point it starts someplace
and we say we are going to be who we
want to be or we're gonna continue being
the killers that we are going to
continue being the killers that we are
that's disgusting stuff you ask people
to serve to protect your community
that's what the police are now there's a
narrative that's developed on the Left
all the way up to the highest levels of
the left that the cops are these thug
killers who are slaughtering people
largely on the basis of their race we
spoke last week at length about that how
that is not true if when you actually
look at the number of unarmed black men
who were killed by the United States you
by police departments across the United
States the number is vanishingly small
and don't forget unarmed does not
necessarily mean
not dangerous unarmed does not
necessarily mean that a killing would
not be justified by law enforcement but
what do we think the number is the way
that they're talking people think the
number is 9000 unarmed black men killed
by cops every year well it's not 9,000
it's not 900 it's not 90 the number is
actually 9 and as other commentators
have gone through we've gone through on
this show even among those nine people
the killings in many to many cases were
justified in the killings are not always
white cops killing black suspects so
it's just a completely false narrative
it is so disrespectful to people who are
actually protecting communities but
these politicians are so Craven that
they're willing to push that narrative
now some politicians don't want to go so
far as to say we need to completely
defund the cops right some are still
trying to walk that line of aggressing
and race hustling and antagonizing
people not going all the way in of
disrupting and dismantling the police
department that would include
minneapolis mayor jacob frye jacob frye
who has been ridiculous this whole time
cow telling this whole time to black
lives matter the movement not the
statement he he went into a group of
these black lives matter protesters and
he was asked point-blank will you defund
the police their reaction his reaction
tells you a whole lot about this
situation we'll get to that in one
second first though first before we get
into the radical aims of this movement
I've got to thank our friends over at
Bambi so when running a business I can
assure you HR issues can kill you you
don't think about them but a lot of
businesses can get smacked by HR issues
think about wrongful termination suits
think about minimum wage requirements
think about labor regulations think
about these days have the regulatory
requirements change I think every single
five minutes HR manager salaries are not
cheap the average HR manager salary is I
kid you not
$70,000 per year but Bambi was created
specifically for small businesses that's
B a.m. Vee you get a dedicated HR
manager craft HR policy and maintain
your compliance all for just $99 a month
with Bambi you can change HR from your
biggest liability to your biggest
and you're dedicated HR manager is
available by phone email or real-time
chat they customize policies to fit your
business all for take a listen to this
just $99 per month months to month no
hidden fees cancel anytime go to bam be
calm / Michael mi CH AE L right now
schedule your free HR audit that is
Bambi calm / Michael mi CH AE L AM - vee
comm / Michael go check it out right now
really really can help your business so
Jacob Frye he wants to walk the line
what Jacob Frye is doing is what I think
a lot of moderate Democrats or even some
moderate Republicans in this country
want to do he wants to accommodate the
radical leftist black lives matter
movement he wants to entertain their
wishes he wants them to like him he
thinks there's some accommodation to be
made between the radical leftist Marxist
how many isms can I possibly fit into
this radical movement BLM movement and
normal policymakers in this country and
he quickly found out that that is not
possible
so initially Frye walks up to them and
he tells them how much he supports their
movie has to take responsibility
I've been coming to grips with my own
brokenness in this situation my own
failures my own shortcomings that I know
there used to be department operates the
systemic the racist system needs to be
[Music]
functions she this woman this activist
takes over at this point but listen to
what what fry does so far fry grants all
their premises what are the premises the
cops are systemically racist the cops
hate black people
the cops are unjust the cops are no-good
dirty-rotten terrible people and then he
says we need to reform it you know if
the cops are so rotten is jacob frye
says that they are how could you
possibly reform it if they are
systemically racist systemically not
just incidently once or twice every so
often but systemically racist then how
are you supposed to reform that thing oh
it's just the police unions put them in
their place he's using all this negative
language and this activist woman very
wisely says okay you're gonna talk a
good game jacob frye well let me ask you
a yes-or-no question because things are
so bad will you or will you not
disband the police
yes he's up for reelection he says no
guess what we don't do next year
now at this point at this point I am
just pleased that this woman still has
any respect at all for elections because
the the way that they're speaking is the
way that revolutionaries speak I've been
to a lot of radical leftist events I've
covered them
I've antagonized them sometimes I've
done both but I've mostly antagonize
them all right and I've heard the way
that they speak I've been to radical
Marxist events this is how they talk
this is radical Marxism okay
dismantling the police is one of the key
features of this because they view the
liberal capitalist state as
intrinsically oppressive and it's the
the cops or the enforcers of that so the
first key to overthrowing the entire
government overthrow the entire society
is to dismantle the cops that's what
they say that they want to do and so
this woman takes control she goes enough
of this mealy-mouthed nonsense are you
or are you not gonna do it because if
you don't we're gonna vote yet thank
goodness she still gives some legitimacy
to elections although frankly I don't
know how much longer that's gonna work
so she gives him a simple question he
gives a simple answer no he doesn't want
to defund the cops and the crowd loses
it
go
so he's gone this huge crowd chases him
out of there in some ways I give him
credit because it is pretty scary to go
into a crowd like this but this guy
thinks this guy thinks with so many
squishes in both parties think which is
that they think maybe black lives matter
is just about black lives matter that's
what I think it's just Oh black lives
matter I agree with that so therefore I
agree with these guys doesn't realize
how extremely far left they are and he
thinks that an accommodation can be made
some kind of coming together
kumbaya we'll meet in the middle
compromise no ain't gonna happen there
are three levels of black lives matter
demands okay black don't forget black
lives matter is an organization it has a
website it has a list of demands it has
a who we are page you go to black lives
matter calm I think it is calm org one
of the two you can go to the website
here's what you expect them to say they
say okay they want to expose and prevent
police brutality they want to stop
unjust deaths at the hands of vigilantes
they want to stop the general racism the
threatens black lives okay right yeah
totally we all get that we all agree
with them there's a little bit less what
you expect but still within the realm of
understanding their black identity runs
in the same way that you have white
identitarian x' they are black
identitarian they say we're
unapologetically black capital B in our
positioning and the capital B matters
here right they're not just saying we're
one group of Americans they're saying
we're black this is a separate thing in
affirming that black lives matter we
need not qualify our position to love
and desire freedom and justice for
ourselves is a prerequisite for wanting
the same for others here's the money
line we see ourselves as part of the
global black community and we're aware
of the different ways we're impacted or
privileged as black people who exist in
different parts of the world so already
you hear a little bit of this more
Marxist language all around the world
transnational not not focusing on bonds
of national loyalty not saying we're
Americans we love America no they're
saying we're part of the global black
community black people of the world who
unite getting a little bit more of an
explicit Marxist message but still
within the realm okay it's called black
lives matter' obviously it's gonna have
a little bit of a black identitarian
component to it then you get to the
craziest level we'll get to that in one
second first though I got to thank our
friends over at first leaf oh how I love
first leaf picture this you're at home
you're relaxing there's not a whole lot
to do outside these days you are
finishing a glass of wine you're just
about to pour another and you you have
this horrifying moment because you
realize there's no backup bottle oh my
gosh what are you supposed to do what
you're gonna pull your hair out this is
terrible but thanks to first leaf you
can get it personalized box of wine
shipped right to your door that's what I
do and I love first leaf I've tried a
lot of different wine companies a lot of
different wine clubs and things like
that
there's no question first leaf is the
best by far you start out by taking a
quick quiz about your wine preferences
but it turns out most people don't
really know what they like in wine
they've just heard a few names sometimes
so firstly it believes you but maybe you
know it tries maybe try this try one or
two over here and then the more you use
it the more you rate the wines the
closer it gets to your perfect palate in
a way that you didn't even know what you
wanted in one I love these guys you know
they gave me a freebie when they started
sponsoring the show and the company is
so good I just said like take my money
or whatever I don't care
I will give me the super duper package
they're they're really tremendous they
have a 100% satisfaction guarantee so if
you receive a bottle that you're not
into they will cover the cost right now
you can get six bottles of wine for only
twenty nine ninety-five which I don't
know if you're so great at mental math
that's extraordinarily inexpensive and
this wine is very high-quality stuff
plus you get free shipping just go to
try first leaf comm slash Noel's canna
wles
that is six bottles of wine for only
twenty nine ninety five really top-shelf
stuff try first leaf calm slash Noel's
head on over there let me know what you
think of it let me know what your
favorite wine is too because I'm still
working out still working out my palate
so so definitely shoot me a message to
let me know okay so basic stuff yeah we
don't bat we don't like racism okay fine
second level we we do like racism in the
sense that we have more racial
solidarity than national solidarity
okay still understandable this is
boilerplate left-wing stuff then the
crazy stuff the
from the black lives matter website we
are self-reflexive and do the work
required to dismantle cisgender
privilege and up uplift black trans folk
huh
what so look don't don't mistake this
they're not intersectional in the way
that leftist politics usually is saying
like yeah you know the Hispanics have
something in common with the Muslims
have something in common with the
lesbian tap dancers have something in
common we're right with all the
disparate oppression groups that then
can go and attack the oppressor group of
straight white men who think that
they're men who come from money who
could write on and on and on that's not
what's happening every qualification
here trans women it's all about being
black which is in a way a little bit
refreshing and leftist politics because
it's a little more old-school it's a
little more old-school Marxism than
whatever has been happening for the last
few decades they say especially we want
to protect black trans women who
continue to be disproportionately
impacted by trans antagonistic violence
all this language cisgender privilege
trans folk is the language of radicals
we build a space that affirms black
women and is free from sexism misogyny
and environments in which men are
centered okay getting more into the
sexual politics we practice empathy we
engage comrades comrades - the intent
with the intent to learn about and
connect with their contexts comrades an
explicitly communist term we make our
spaces family-friendly and enable
parents to fully participate with their
children we dismantle the patriarchal
practice that requires mothers to work
double shifts okay so now the patriarchy
is involved here and then this is the
money line we disrupt the Western
proscribed nuclear family structure
requirement by supporting each other as
extended families and villages that
collectively care for one another
especially for our children to the
degree that mothers parents and children
are comfortable if you support the
nuclear family then you are standing in
opposition to black lives matter the
Western proscribed nuclear family as
they put it and then we foster queer
firming Network when we gather we do so
with the intention to free ourselves
from the tight grip of heteronormative
thinking or rather the belief that all
in the world are heterosexual unless she
he rub they disclose otherwise right to
the same kind of sexual revolutionary
language it is not possible to be a
conservative and to support the black
lives matter movement it is not possible
to be a reasonable person and support
the black lives matter movement a lot of
conservatives even conservatives a lot
of reasonable people think they support
the black lives matter movement because
they think the black lives matter and
they think the black lives matter
movement is about how black lives matter
that's not what it's about okay I think
the best analogy would be what they do
in Congress you know I'm looking down
the street I can see the Capitol down
the street this is what they do in
Congress whenever there's a really bad
bill really ugly awful legislation that
is really harmful to people they give it
a really nice sounding name so you can
almost judge how bad a bill is by how
nice the name sounds they will cram in
the worst policies ever and then they'll
call the bill the don't murder puppies
Act of 2020 they'll say okay congressmen
are you gonna vote for the don't murder
puppies act of 2020 and then you're in a
bad spot because you say actually that
bill is really terrible and includes all
this stuff that everyone's gonna hate
that's going to destroy all of our lives
but they'll say but it's called the
don't murder puppies Act so you got a
support it's the same thing with black
lives matter let's say you hold that you
don't support black lives matter what
are you a racist what are you a bigot
what are you a white supremacist
neo-nazi
Klansmen Nazi supremacists you say no I
just you know I don't think we should
destroy the family so I can't they tell
me that if I support the family I can't
support BLM and that's true that's
exactly what's going on here and I get
it there are a lot of people who posted
the stupid square on social media
because basically everybody pressured
them into doing it and you don't want to
lose your job if you didn't do it you
thought it meant that you support black
people so now what it means do not
support black lives matter
no one should support this terrible
terrible radical leftist disastrous
awful how many more bad adjectives can I
use organization it's not possible to
support your country to support your
family to support any sort of reasonable
politics and support this radical
movement and they should be shunned from
the mainstream of radical politics
before they do even more damage
like for instance destroy the cops we
have got to get two more terrible things
they're doing because now they're trying
to push legal discrimination in
corporate America now they're trying to
get rid of your cop shows on TV and some
people even the woke left are beginning
to wake up we'll get to that in one
second first though I've got to thank
our friends over at Ray Khan
you know ray Conner but first of all
first of all if you are listening to
anything in 2020 and you still have
wires dangling now if you're like on the
train or whatever you're in your cut and
you've got the wires dangling down you
got to get rid of that okay you need
wireless earbuds and you know some
wireless earbuds are a little overpriced
and they make you look like an alien or
a bug ray condom start about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
just as amazing as other top audio
brands you know their newest model the
everyday II 25-year buds are their best
ones yet with six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass in
a more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit ray cons
wireless earbuds are so comfortable that
especially these days when you know
maybe you got some more conference calls
maybe you're doing a little more work
around the house they're just perfect
they look cool they sound great in the
price is extraordinarily fair and
reasonable now is the time to get the
latest and greatest from Ray Con and
then what I will do for you is I will
give you 15% off when you go to buy
Raycom slash knowles that's by Ray [ __ ]
comm slash Knowles for 15% off a break
on wireless earbuds by rakin comm slash
Knowles all right so it's not just about
even dismantling the cops though that's
a pretty bad there is now in the name of
anti racism a lot of racism it's being
pushed maybe you found this when you
order an uber eats over the weekend uber
eats is now waiving delivery fees for
black owned
this is what is a black-owned business I
don't know something tells me though all
of a sudden you're gonna see a lot of
companies start giving at point zero
zero zero zero zero one percent of
equity to some black person so they
qualify for this so that they can now
get the free free delivery on a new
breed's here's what the CEO of uber read
said Dora chose Rocha Shahi as a company
we believe that everyone has the right
to move freely no matter where they live
or the color of their skin we're proud
of how Ober has helped improve
transportation equity over the last
decade transportation equity that's I
guess that's a new liberal slogan that
we've got to add to the list
transportation equity but the reality
remains that black Americans often don't
feel safe to move freely in many places
around the country and they still face
enormous barriers that others do not so
Hoover now is focusing on their main
business which is you know a taxicab
business basically and they're saying
look we care a lot about black people in
black communities and we've helped them
to move around freely I wish that the
lives of George Floyd Ahmad our burry
Brianna Taylor and countless others
weren't so violently cut short I wish
that institutional racism and the police
violence that gives rise to didn't cause
their deaths so corporate America buying
into the lie that there is a systemic
scourge of racist cops slaughtering
innocent black people around the country
not true not backed up by any statistics
completely imaginary and causing real
harm in the real world but you got
corporate America backing it up too
there's this lie that the left believes
that corporate America is very very
conservative corporate America pushes
leftism corporate America at the very
least rolls over for leftism whether
it's based on lies with whether it's
based on the lie that men can become
women
the minute that that becomes in any way
a social movement corporate America
rolls over gets rid of same-sex
bathrooms forces everybody to go through
brainwashing trainings where we all
recite endlessly that men really are
women or else she'll be written up by HR
or something like that same thing here
the minute it becomes part of a social
movement that cops are racist and
terrible and slaughtering people
willy-nilly based on their race then
they just start spouting this and by the
way
you go around the water cooler at your
office and you contradict this in any
way you could lose your job we spoke
offline so you can check it out it's
wasn't on the show but it was on my
youtube channel on the michael noland
show YouTube channel we spoke to a
friend of mine Tim Gordon the author he
was teaching a Catholic High School he
pointed out how radical black lives
matter is he said he didn't support them
because you know for instance they want
to destroy the family he was fired for
that Catholic High School which
ostensibly believes exactly what he
spoke he believes but they don't really
that's corporate America pushes this
it's not just the government and so now
Ober eats is giving free delivery to
black owned businesses this is this is
basic racial discrimination this is
almost certainly against the law and
it's funny because I pointed this out on
Twitter I said this is obviously against
the law for this business to
discriminate on the basis of race and I
had lawyers quibbling with me in the
comment section when one lawyer or some
liberal lawyer says this is that's
ridiculous this is not discriminatory
this is not a violation of the law and
then you have more conservative lawyers
saying you know yes it is based on the
Civil Rights Act based on title 7 my
point is actually beyond any of that the
law is how we interpret the law okay we
know that there have but we talked about
this last week a little bit too there's
the written law and you can quibble over
the written law every single day then
there's the practical law the way the
law is actually enforced and the
applications of the Civil Rights Act now
govern virtually every aspect of our law
so the way that I know that this is
illegal or would would be illegal and
the letter of the law is imagine imagine
if uber eats flipped it imagine if you
burries said we're going to give free
delivery for white owned businesses and
we're gonna charge delivery fees for
black owned businesses can you even
imagine the lawsuits it would be the
minute they announced that their phones
would explode from the lawsuits that
would be coming in from the complaints
that are coming in I guess for the way
the lawsuits would come in is they get a
knock on the door but it would explode
instantly now is it going to explode
because it's the other way around
probably not I mean it's there is an
irony to all of this which is if we're
talking
actual legal racism there's only one
policy in the country that permits legal
discrimination and actually encourages
it and that's called affirmative action
which does not which is not legal racism
in the way that the leftist activists
are saying that it is actually it
disadvantages the other people who are
supposed to be the oppressors and most
of all it actually disadvantages Asian
students which is why Asian students
sued Harvard University because they
said that there was there were
discriminatory admissions practices that
disadvantaged Asians on the basis of
their race and helped other races on the
basis of their race that is legal
racial discrimination not not according
to the left-wing narrative but that's
what we're seeing and that practice is
permitted affirmative action has been
upheld by the Supreme Court so very
likely the same thing would happen to
something like uber eats doesn't make it
right doesn't make it legal according to
the letter of the law but but where we
are right now is in this radical
movement and I got to tell you folks you
thought two months ago that things
couldn't get crazier in politics then
left-wing activists started torching
cities then yello-ha no more talks about
defunding the police and it looks like
they're actually doing it then she talks
about the Committee of Public Safety
you know things happen gradually then
suddenly and we are moving into some
unchartered radical territory here we'll
see how far it goes The Washington Post
has one solution to the problem we'll
get to that in one second cancel police
TV shows which frankly is a step too far
you can get rid of my cops but you
cannot get rid of my law and order love
lon order that's the best way to just
turn your brain off at the end of the
day and we'll get to that we'll get to
some work leftists waking up Shaun King
believe it or not Shaun King a very
left-wing problm L BLM activist kind of
getting a little bit more woke on all of
this Jake here Alan we'll get to that in
just a bit but first I've got to thank
you I'm gonna thank you and I have to
tell you about a new area of the website
a new tier of membership that we've got
because when you can't get the true
stories from the mainstream media and I
think we all know you cannot get the
true story from the mainstream media
then you've got to get the facts you got
to collect the facts you're
and you can get the facts you can get
the facts with the readers pass from
daily wire.com we've got some really
premium content that we put on the
website but you can only get it if you
are a member and you get the readers
past so usually look this is extremely
cheap it's like three bucks a month I'm
gonna give you two thirds off of that
today because I think it's really
important especially now to make sure
that you arm yourself with this
information so you can go over there
right now you get your first month for
99 cents you'll also get access to our
mobile app get push notifications for
breaking news and special content as
well as joining the community of Daily
wire members who are actively commenting
and discussing the content with each
other that's mobile ad free access to
the daily wire news exclusive op-eds
more free mobile app all for the low
price of one dollar head on over to
daily wire comm slash subscribe and join
today we'll be right back with a lot
more
wopo has the answer
shut down cop shows now a kid you're not
this is this is their solution to
alleged police brutality like many other
industries entertainment companies have
issued statements of support for the
protests against racism and police
brutality now filling America's streets
but there's something Hollywood can do
to put its money where its mouth is
immediately halt production of cop shows
and movies and rethink the stories it
tells about policing in America I just
other reason I mentioned this is to just
point out the difference between the
fantasy of how the world is working in
the reality of it in the fantasy version
of the world cops have a ton of power
cops are vicious they're slaughtering
people on the basis of their race
there's no way for us to stop them so we
got a muster all the power of the people
and try to crack crack their oppressive
power structure in reality the opposite
is true in reality right now everybody
hates that hates the cops based on
nothing based on a completely fictional
narrative so much so that they're
actually trying to write the cops out of
popular culture even though cops or
getting sniped left and right during
these riots cops lives are not
considered to matter at all by the
popular culture cops go out they serve
are there some bad cops every once in a
while sure but the vast vast majority
are good people trying to help the
country out they get no respect they get
no support now even from the popular
culture some people are waking up to
this even Shaun King who is one of the
BLM leaders Shaun King is pointing out
that hey wait a second guys we are sort
of the power structure because they all
say keep going you got to go out and
vote you got to go out and vote for
Democrats he says wait a second quote
stop generically telling us to vote in
response to all of the police brutality
we have right now yes we should vote but
we have to be very specific Democrats
from top to bottom are running the
cities with the worst police brutality
in America right now we voted for them
thank you thank you man look I actually
wasn't even able to see that tweet
initially because Shaun King blocked me
on Twitter because I'm too mean to him I
think usually but I was able to see the
tweet I'm like incognito window somebody
sent it to me and he's right he's right
but maybe this is baked into the cake
made
the reason that the left is causing this
destruction the left is encouraging this
mayhem is to tighten their own power
because when there's civil disorder then
we turn to the authorities even more and
more I wondered I mean this is a little
bit too for DHS and I don't necessarily
give leftists like keith Ellison credit
for for DHS but the AG of Minnesota you
remember keith Ellison increase the
charge against the cop involved in the
killing of George Floyd he increased it
from third degree murder which would be
I think pretty easy to prove to
second-degree murder showing you know
you'd have to show them that the cop
really really wanted to kill George
Floyd I don't think that's easy to prove
I think it'll be harder I think there's
a chance the cop walks if the cop walks
that would seem to contradict what these
guys want to do but maybe not maybe the
left once this cop to walk so that
there's even more chaos and mayhem and
they can make an even stronger plea next
election cycle that I think is what
Shaun King is starting to catch on to a
little bit so what is he advocating for
it nothing yet he's just waking up to a
little bit of the grift now this goes
all the way up to the top Attorney
General William Bart was asked on CBS
News about this charge of systemic
racism and Barr gave what I think is
maybe the most reasonable answer on the
whole thing do you believe there is
systemic racism in law enforcement I
think there's racism in the United
States still but I don't think that the
law enforcement system is systemically
racist I understand the distrust however
of the african-american community given
the history in this country this is a
three-part answer I think it's totally
reasonable and I think conservatives
should take this to heart when we're
trying to figure out what to replace
this absurd agree with BLM narrative
with I think bar gives us a good answer
which is one yeah I think there's racism
in America because the imagination of
man's heart is evil from the beginning
there are there are always these sort of
nefarious things lurking in man's heart
by the way we're never going to get rid
of that that's not possible in America
is the least racist whatever the word is
said to me in these days the least
racist country that has ever existed in
the history of the world but putting
that aside yes there will always be some
kind
sin crouching and man's heart and you're
not gonna get rid of that but we can try
to keep it in check we can try to
practice the virtues and repent of our
sin or the police systemically racist no
no evidence for it at all put that idea
away with the Tooth Fairy and the Easter
Bunny it just ain't true
and then three do black Americans have a
point in being a little skeptical of the
cops yes I think I think so
like just historically speaking there
have been power imbalances in the
country and so it's I think perfectly
reasonable to have this feeling of
skepticism however you've got to counter
your feeling of skepticism by looking at
the facts and the facts show there is no
systemic racism so the feeling of unease
sure understandable but the reality
simply not the case
and if you need any further evidence
that maybe it's not such a good idea to
disband the cops because there's no
evidence that we should do that at all
look at the leaders occasionally the
leaders break through into the
mainstream media never on the left-wing
channels but at least Fox News the
right-leaning cable news channel
interviewed one of the leaders one of
the peaceful rioters of this movement
and what do you think he was talking
about what do you think he was promoting
was he promoting this idea that we
should all go out and you know come
together and kumbaya no he was
threatening to burn down the diamond
district of New York you know I'm a
leader of this ftv movement it means a
lot of things it could mean free to
people it could be for the people it
could also mean fired to property you
know that's very possible today I'm
leading a demonstration from Barclays
Center at 6:00 p.m. to City Hall and
that's the first stop and we're hoping
DeBlasio and Cuomo come out and talk to
us and give the youth some direction but
if they don't the next stop is a diamond
district and gasoline thanks the truck
is awfully cheap gasoline thanks to
Trump is awfully cheap there's actually
a secondary racial component to this
which is that the diamond district in
New York is run by Jews and among the
so-called peaceful black identitarian
leaders in New York there's been a
little bit of hostility historically
with the Jews there you know I give this
guy credit the FTP movement which he
says is for the people free the people
what it really means is if the police
I give him credit for using that rates
because FTP is a little more honest
about the radical aims and the radical
tenor of the movements a lot more honest
than BLM but all in all basically the
same thing some people are getting a
little bit woke not not even on the
issue of cops or BLM but just on the
radicalism of leftist politics generally
JK Rowling who is a card-carrying lefty
she's the author of the Harry Potter
books she came out against the idea that
men can be women right so one of the
more extreme versions of left-wing
politics and she's now incurred the ire
of the woke mob
she wrote the idea that women like me
who've been emphatic or empathetic
rather to trans people for decades
feeling kinship because they're
vulnerable in the same way as women it
asked to male violence hate trans people
because they think sex is real and has
live consequences is a nonsense
I respect every trans person's right to
live any way that feels authentic and
comfortable to them I'd mark with I'd
walk with you if you were discriminated
against on the basis of being trans at
the same time my life has been shaped by
being female I do not believe it's
hateful to say so she's trying to try to
do the same thing that the squishers are
trying to do on BLM she's trying to come
to an accommodation with this insane
radical ideology that a man is really a
woman you can't there's no there's no
accommodation with that there's no like
halfway men or men and they can't be
women or men really are women and sex is
not real there's no middle ground of men
or kind of women sometimes or whatever
no it's not you got to pick one
subjective reality okay and the problem
is she's trying to say look I respect
people she's trying to use all this
language no I mean you does she
obviously doesn't respect every trans
person's right to live any way that
feels authentic and comfortable maybe
they feel authentic and comfortable you
if they're a man who particularly
pretends that they're a woman maybe they
feel authentic and comfortable using the
women's room but what you're saying is
they can't use the women's room maybe
they feel authentic and comfortable
playing in women's sports you're saying
they can't play in women's sports okay
maybe they are being discriminated
against on the basis of being trans in
the sense that you're not allowing them
to do the things that they want to do
based on a manifestly untrue delusion
namely that the men are women and the
women are men you've got to make a
choice and you can't keep trying to be
the nice guy you can't keep trying to
buy into the premises that the left is
giving you that if you if you if you
disagree with the craziest most radical
things they're saying that somehow
you're a bad person that simply isn't
true I this is an amazing story out of
speaking of the intersectional leftist
hierarchy there's an amazing story that
la pride and like the used to be gay
pride now I guess just pride generally
la pride has been cancelled because now
we're in LA wrasse month now pride is
gone now we're in wrath of their
torching the cities but the pride the
Pride Parade was cancelled because of
coronavirus remember that yeah me
neither
then pride was reorganized as a black
solidarity March wait a second hold on
the virus is so bad that you can't have
the gay pride parade but now that it's
going to be a black Pride Parade you can
do it it's going to march and sell but
actually now it's been canceled again
because gay pride has a good
relationship with the cops and BLM hates
the cops so now gay pride has to get rid
of the cops and now they can't March
even though they weren't supposed to
March in the first place because of the
virus which by the way is super duper
series I'm gonna kill us all that's what
the public health experts told us but
they were gonna march back when it was
gonna be a black parade because if
you're if you're marching with the
radical black movement then you're not
gonna get the virus what is this very
difficult to make any sense of it the
virus part of it is is one that's been
lost which is that we are told the virus
is gonna kill us all but then whenever
it is convenient for leftist protesters
or rioters or arsonists or looters all
of a sudden the virus goes away ouchy is
already setting it up that we've got to
worry about the virus again
he said we're now in a perfect setup for
further spread of the virus in the sense
that creating these blips which might
turn into some surges so already you
tell us the virus is super serious then
left us to go out in the streets it's
not serious now they're setting us up
again don't get fooled again do not get
fooled again to quote george w bush fool
me once shame on you fool me twice the
point is you're not gonna fool me again
we'll get to george w bush in a second
because george w bush says he's not
going to support Trump and it actually
ties in with everything we've been
talking about
if you right now if you search on
Twitter if you go to Twitter and you
type in racist and you clades a people
search so you click on the people tab
type in a racist you're the first name
to come up President Trump because
presumably someone at Twitter is having
a little bit of fun someone at Twitter
presumably is smearing the President as
a racist private company Twitter sort of
can they they impart along with their
other big tech oligarchs control the
flow of information around the whole
internet going after President Trump
it's a terrible no-good rotten racist
corporate America giving in to this
nonsense the media obviously getting
into this nonsense the bureaucracy and
trying to snipe president from for so
long I've been dragged snipe
conservatives for so long though the
whole edifice turning on anybody who
wants to do anything as a conservative
and now you've got three moderate more
liberal Republicans coming out saying
they won't support Trump : Powell
that's no surprise : Powell's been half
a Democrat for his whole career
President George W Bush Trump's
Republican predecessor and Mitt Romney
Trump's Republican presidential nominee
all three saying they will not support
Trump for re-election no surprise
because Trump's been really tough on
bush I've he's been really tough on
President Bush and he's been tough on
Romney really deservedly too Romney but
look they come from the liberal wing of
the Republican Party and Trump whatever
you think about his ideological vision
and his philosophical formation he
certainly is now on the conservative
wing of the Republican Party this is the
problem the problem isn't even that the
radicals are gonna be radicals that the
radicals are gonna try to do things like
defund the police and destroy the family
and just knock our society down to
rubble and in many cities so far
actually reduce our cities to rubble the
problem is these squishes who go along
with it because the the the argument
here I mean this is from George W Bush
this is george w bush published a letter
on this basically said yeah
saying that Trump isn't bringing people
together : Powell said I can't support
president Trump or you know I can't vote
for him this year because the
president's drifted from the
Constitution Ritz to there's too much
rancor there's too much hatred and well
okay where's the rancor coming from it's
all being directed at Trump by the
bureaucracy by the media by the radical
activists by the Marxists by Hollywood
right there it's all being directed at
Trump and they hate Trump so much
because he's actually doing something
he's actually fulfilling some of his
promises he is by far the most
conservative president we've had
certainly in my lifetime probably
include including Reagan maybe all the
way back to Calvin Coolidge or further
back right so he's actually doing
something he's not just playing around
he's not just a nice Republican who
gives enough resistance to the liberal
order to illegitimate the order but not
enough to actually work the left-wingers
he's not doing that he's actually
threatening them and so they've been
trying to undermine him since day one
they've been trying to throw him out of
office they've been trying to impeach
him over nothing
multiple multiple times and this makes
the liberal Republicans uncomfortable
they say gosh things have gotten so
heated that we can't do this Joe Biden
said this he said we can't continue like
this for another four years the implicit
threat here is that if you don't elect a
Democrat we're gonna burn your city
we're gonna keep burning your cities
down and the implicit squishy Republican
argument here is look the Democrats are
burning our cities down the Democrats
really don't like this in the spirit of
unity let's give in let's cave in let's
give them everything that they want
Chris Cuomo is going on CNN defending
domestic terrorism okay defending
political violence against civilians
you can't come to an accommodation with
that you can't negotiate with that you
can't reconcile and kumbaya and come to
the middle okay you gotta win or you
gotta lose and there's some people right
now who want to lose because they can't
stand the heat literal heat when the
radical leftists are torching buildings
in the country
stand firm man this is the fight okay we
are in the fight right now and the
stakes are very high the stakes are not
just we're gonna raise your taxes a
little bit or we're gonna lower your
taxes a little bit the stakes are we're
gonna defund the police department we're
going to defund law enforcement itself
and the reason we're going to do that is
so that we can totally overhaul the
legal and political structure of this
country maybe you didn't ask for the
fight but you are in the fight now and
it's only going to get hotter up through
November got a lot more to get to we'll
have to do it tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael noses the
mic on I'll show see that
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there